yeah I hate to say it but I do think
you're gonna have to find someone else
to host that charity gala I knew you'd
understand thanks Barack there's never
enough time these days
one minute you're reading Tolstoy the
next you're giving your friend Keanu a
ride to the airport and then all of a
sudden you're late to that wine-tasting
class you teach every Thursday at the
Met things are getting crazy so while I
appreciate getting my $60 worth with
triple-a videogames it stresses me out
just thinking about replaying any of
this year's releases games a service
require daily commitments before you
reach their end game titles like sake
hero demand weeks of laser focus to
master that's not to mention RPGs those
holiest of games that can require dozens
of hours just to finish their main quest
lines sure I love Fire Emblem three
houses and yeah if I had an extra day
each week I might start a second
playthrough maybe then I could stoop to
the level of the Black Eagles over the
other better houses but I don't have
eight days and the Black Eagles are all
jerks that's why I appreciate the outer
worlds it's the mini RPG I didn't know I
needed it understands that quantity does
not equal quality it knows that value is
not always a matter of length in a year
of stealth hits and creative releases
the outer worlds despite being an RPG is
the single game I restarted immediately
after beating it clocking in at around
25 hours the outer worlds is pretty
brief for its John Rowe at least
and while naysayers may consider this a
fault I think it's actually one of the
game's greatest strengths it trims the
fat removing needless grinding and
boring miscellaneous quests it ensures
that no storyline overstays its welcome
it also brings more vitality to its
characters than most 80 hour RPGs could
ever manage like Parvati for example
everyone who has played the outer worlds
now has a photo of Parvati taped to the
ceiling above their bed literally
everyone and not just me do you think
that's a coincidence
no it's a testament to the depth of
character this sci-fi world allows
whether it's Parvati's romance side
quest or the relationship challenges she
faces as an asexual person or the way
she plays good cop to your bad cop
in the middle of conversations all of it
holds weight because in an RPG that
knows when to can end I'm content to
linger on every narrative threat of
course the outer world isn't good just
because it's not 60 hours long some of
my favorite games taking dozens of hours
to finish first 105 clocked in at around
90 in 2017 and it's one of my favorite
titles of this console generation what
makes the outer worlds good to me is
that it respects players time
investments it showcases an efficiency
of design that you don't often see in
other words I can't really label one
questline or one character as
unnecessary trust me I tried take Ellie
for example the hardened smuggler is
essential because she balances out
Parvati's naivete her companion quest is
crucial because it explains her
roguishness the city that quest line
takes place in is critical because it
showcases a side of the late capitalist
dystopia that we haven't seen much of up
until that point it shows the people who
are benefiting from the halcyon colony's
brutal class differences and speaking of
Halcyon the outer worlds overarching
structure also demonstrates this density
of content rather than taking the
fallout route of massive sandbox
exploration the outer worlds relies on
discrete locations which you can take
your time poring over surprisingly this
actually manages to impart a sense of
scale that I don't always get from an
Elder Scrolls or a far cry I hate myself
for saying this because it's really
cliche but the outer worlds feels
lived-in
the story had built climaxed and said
farewell but I wanted to experience all
of it again that expert concoction of
moral dilemmas pitch perfect pacing and
Parvati pulled me back in as soon as the
credits rolled I'm now halfway through
my second adventure avoiding the speech
skills of my first character for one
more focused on just brute strength
I'm trying new weapons and ability perks
sure but I'm also enjoying the
role-playing of the thing knowing that
each and every hour of this succinct
epic will yield exciting scenarios
I'm exhausting every well-written
dialogue option I'm pressing my
companions emotional buttons I'm poking
at this world so to speak attempting to
find the cracks but so far I have
found many the outer worlds isn't
memorable because it's not ridiculously
long it's memorable because well it
doesn't waste any of its time more
importantly it doesn't waste any of mine
and that's no easy feat more RPGs should
pay attention going forward and more
RPGs should have Parvati
[Music]
you